following total atomic annihilation the
rebuilding of this great nation of ours
may fall to you that's why we at Walt
tech have prepared these educational
materials for you to better understand
seven defining attributes that make you
special got your rabbit's foot good it's
time we talk about luck the difference
between whether you live or die in the
post nuclear world may depend on the
flip of a coin luck is a mysterious sort
of curiosity see here a well-placed shot
may not always do the trick if Lady Luck
favors you though you'll find those
critical moments a breeze what's this
only scrounging up dubs time and
patience may net you a suitable
collection but with luck on your side
you're bound to find some swell keepers
no no hold on to anything shiny it may
be of hidden value be careful not to get
distracted by your newfound fortunes
oh that wasn't the only test it looks
like luck has helped you once again
unfortunately she can't save you from
every situation at least your misfortune
can become someone else's fortune
luck may be fickle but if you can lu her
to your side the possibilities are
endless but particularly bloody mess
will look a chance to build a streak of
destruction that cut the magic of the
unexpected all regularly studying your
vortex provided materials to prepare for
survival and to answer the question do
you know what makes you special